hey what's going on is Bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday January 21st 2019 what's going on
how how's it going everybody how was
your weekend of playoff football I'll
tell you right now if you didn't have a
[ __ ] if you didn't have a [ __ ] dog
in that flight you just sat back and
enjoyed both of those [ __ ] crazy
games sort of I guess yeah I don't even
know where to begin
all I can just say is overall both of
those games is exactly what the NFL
wants which is heart attack [ __ ]
football games and I know there was a
lot of [ __ ] given to the refs but I
think so much of it is them just
applying 20 years of rule changes that
all essentially benefit the offense
it drives me [ __ ] nuts I know I
always sound like an old man but I hate
it I [ __ ] I can't stand it I know my
team won but I fight those [ __ ] games
sucked
yesterday okay I just I can't fight him
I don't know I don't know where to begin
I mean if that's what the [ __ ] you want
to watch just two teams just going up
and down the field up can you believe my
god they scored 59 56 if you want to
[ __ ] watch that for a goddamn 3 hours
you know what I mean you like some
[ __ ] fat kid who wants to go right to
dessert you know no one wants to eat
their vegetables no one wants to see any
[ __ ] defense I don't even know where
to begin
I actually somehow sat through the
Patriots game just sitting there you
know I got my daughter now so it's like
I'm not gonna be this guy flipping out
and everything like that and I was able
to remain calm
until 39 seconds left in the game and
after that I just lost my [ __ ] where I
was just like this is so [ __ ] I was
already watching like the Chiefs no you
know what the first time I lost my [ __ ]
was when it was there was 954 to go in
the game we had fourth in a yard or a
half of the yard and we had essentially
for the NFL a chip shot field goal which
would have put us up by six okay
and I'm thinking and and we go for it
and we don't get it and what [ __ ]
kills me was no one gave Belichick any
[ __ ] because that's just the way the
games played now it's like you'd be up
by six even if the Chiefs go down the
field and score a touchdown they're only
gonna be up by one and now you can go
down the field kick a field goal go up
by two or score a touchdown and put it
away for the [ __ ] life of me I don't
understand the way the game is played
now and I guess because I'm sitting they
go I'm just a stand-up [ __ ] comedian
he's Bill Belichick obviously he knows
what's what you're supposed to do here I
think there's just so many rules that
are in favor of the offense that you
just know the other teams essentially
going to score
we can't that taken three points is like
us like not I don't know it's like not
kicking an extra point who gives a [ __ ]
I have no idea I don't [ __ ] get it I
haven't said that I know there's a bunch
of people upset about the officiating
and you know I mean I'm with I'm with
you on it
I don't think all of them were bad calls
I just think there's just a bunch of bad
rules that totally tipped it in the
favor of the offense if you just look in
the last year Tom Brady threw 500 yards
in a Super Bowl and lost
Patrick mahomes is a rookie quarterback
and he threw 50 [ __ ] touchdowns I'm
not saying the guy isn't great he's
[ __ ] unbelievable I love him ok but
50 touchdowns by a rookie there's
something wrong
with the league last week we tackled
Philip Rivers while he had the ball and
we got caught for rut we got called for
roughing the passer this week I watched
the Chiefs the guys hand I think it
caused air that that disrupted Tom
Brady's eyelash not even eyelashes his
eyelash and they got called for roughing
the [ __ ] passer then Patrick mahomes
actually got hit which was also a
[ __ ] love tap a love tap and he's
wearing a helmet and I saw him look at
the ref and I when I was watching the
game I was like all right rook you're
gonna get that call in two to three
years you don't have the seniority yet
to get that call but Tom Brady gets that
call but vets always get the calls all
right but that [ __ ] [ __ ] where as an
offensive lineman is pushing you down
and your only thing is you can dive at
the quarterbacks legs and you actually
sack them and then they call you for
roughing the passer I mean I don't know
what to [ __ ] do with that I don't
know but you know if Chiefs fans are
gonna whine about the ref the
officiating you know will whine about
that non-call and your [ __ ] pick play
too I mean let's be fair about it I also
as a Patriots fan I was surprised that
they reversed the call on Edelman
touching it because on the replay it
looks like he doesn't touch it but you
can't say that it didn't touch his
forearm hair I guess they went with the
ball didn't change any sort of direction
wobbles stopped or anything that I was
surprised they switched that but all you
[ __ ] whining page of Patriot haters
out there who say the referees love us
you're really forgetting the flake gate
Roger Goodell [ __ ] hates us the
league does not like us okay they
allowed the owner of another team to
conduct his own private investigation
this wasn't the league it was the owner
who paid a guy to dig up dirt and the
dirt II found he also found with the
Colts they completely ignored all of
that suspended our quarterback the
golden boy don't touch him suspended him
initially more than they suspended
guy on the Ravens who [ __ ] knocked
his wife out on video in a [ __ ]
elevator so I don't know what world
you're living in I think he just sick of
[ __ ] losing to us and I will go with
that the officiating was terrible I'll
go with that the [ __ ] rules are
terrible but I don't I stop short of
that the refs love the Patriots yeah
Roger Goodell [ __ ] hates us and he
did everything he could [ __ ] do to
suspend our quarterback which he ended
up doing he actually lost it into a
court of law and then like the little
[ __ ] [ __ ] that he is he went back and
completely switched his argument not
that the Patriots are cheating was that
that they were a corporation Tom Brady's
an employee doesn't a corporation have
the right to suspend an employee and the
court was like yeah fine he's our
employee he's suspended all right so if
that's loving us I don't know what to
tell you I haven't said that my heart
goes out to [ __ ] Chiefs fans I was
actually you know at one point being
like all right if the Chiefs win this
then I can just [ __ ] relax during a
[ __ ] Super Bowl I can watch old NFL
classic old NFL team the Rams versus a
classic old AFL team in the Chiefs and
and I could just [ __ ] enjoy a goddamn
Super Bowl for once without having to
[ __ ] sit there you know having a
[ __ ] heart attack while the whole
world's watching wanting your [ __ ]
team to lose and then have to listen to
comments for a year like Nick Foles kick
Tom Brady's ass when he threw for almost
half as many [ __ ] yards it's like now
he beat the Patriots defense the only
guy would say he beat Tom Brady was
[ __ ] Eli Manning because Eli Manning
is the only guy in a game I think Tom
Brady could questionably say he [ __ ]
up when he threw to Welker through the
back shoulder welcome probably should
have caught it who the [ __ ] knows I'll
give you that one but other than that
every [ __ ] Super Bowl tom has drove
the team down the [ __ ] field for the
winning touchdown
it's our defense that [ __ ] it up like
yesterday 39 [ __ ] seconds left and
with these [ __ ] rule changes
we're up by three points you kick it
away you attack him on the twenty day
driving all the way to [ __ ] that do two
[ __ ] offensive plays and they're on
our twenty yard line
if there was forty nine seconds left
they would have had a chance to throw it
into the [ __ ] endzone like that was
when I was up off the couch when it went
into overtime at that point I didn't
even give a [ __ ] who won the game I was
just like [ __ ] this this is even [ __ ]
football anymore it's a [ __ ] joke
it's just it's just Madden Instagram
every [ __ ] game now is they've
changed the rules to the point where
it's gonna turn into the the 40 of the
Miami Dolphins San Diego Chargers which
was a a game of the decade happens like
every three weeks now now I know I sound
like a [ __ ] curmudgeon here but like
I don't know I miss I miss great
defenses with nicknames and [ __ ] I guess
the last one maybe was Seattle with
legion of boom but I don't even think
that took off I think that that was just
in Seattle where everybody used to say
doomsday purple people eaters Steel
Curtain the sack exchange all of that
[ __ ] I don't know let me ask you this
guys who's the [ __ ] Ronnie lot in the
league right now
who's the Jack Lambert where's the
[ __ ] Ray Lewis they just they don't
[ __ ] exist they're not allowed to
play the [ __ ] game if you can tackle
a quarterback with the [ __ ] ball and
that's roughing the passer man I don't
know what the [ __ ] to tell you and
furthermore people who keep saying that
Tom Brady's the greatest of all time
it's still Joe Montana to me Joe Montana
went four in one decade with two
different coaches he'll his Bill
Belichick quit and you allowed to beat
the [ __ ] out of the quarterback so if
Joe Montana plays today Bill Walsh
sticks around like Bill Belichick does
and he doesn't take that hit against the
Giants and he plays into his 40s I think
he can get five all right I know in this
first 10 minutes you wouldn't know that
my team won but like you know I don't
know I just don't listen to me I'm just
an old [ __ ] man who's watched the
game change and I'm acting like who was
that guy that played for the Eagles he
was the last guy to start both ways and
there was an NFL film
clip of him because he used to always
[ __ ] on the new games the new players
because they didn't start both ways
and he'd be like I wouldn't watch a
football game good day of your paper
anyways so that's my take I don't think
the referees love the Patriots I just
think that it's it's just all about the
offenses now having said that talking
about the Saints and the [ __ ] Rams
these Saints absolutely got royally
[ __ ] over times - by the referees
because it wasn't like that play was
away from the ball it was where the ball
was going and there was two major major
[ __ ] penalties on that play that have
literally changed the game to the point
you have a rookie quarterback throwing
for 50 [ __ ] touchdowns that was pass
interference and helmet-to-helmet
contact the whole [ __ ] stadium was
looking where the ball went you know
that Kansas City pick play that no
Kansas City fan is gonna [ __ ] bring
up when they whine about the officiating
I can see them missing that play you
know you're watching the [ __ ] ball
there's you know four or five players
all [ __ ] moving at the same time but
that was I don't know I don't get that
and people who argue that the Saints
could have put the Rams away you're
acting as though the Rams aren't the
ramps who it's looking like they have
the next Bill Belichick on their hands
as a head coach who's only like [ __ ]
33 34 years old now it's gonna take 60
minutes to put them away I usually like
that argument that you know you've you
know you got to put a team away when you
have a chance to put a team away I
wouldn't use that with the Saints
because the Rams are too good a [ __ ]
team to be like well we handled them and
a half let's just [ __ ] and play our game
and chew up the clock and you know and
we can just win this one going away
I would've used that argument against
the Patriots where we should have kicked
that [ __ ] field goal I just don't
understand going for it
we're up by three [ __ ] points and
you're going for it like there's no time
left on the [ __ ] clock and you're
down by four but that's you know I guess
that's how the [ __ ] games played so
here we go another Super Bowl the Chiefs
are the team of the future though in the
AFC even if believe it or not this is a
rebuilding year for the Patriots having
lost all the talent a free agent that we
have so the fact that they made it to
another [ __ ] Super Bowl is ridiculous
but like I said I don't know I'm sure
this is coming off like what the [ __ ]
but like I don't I don't sit there and
talk [ __ ] and rub other [ __ ] people
you know like I played that noses in it
all I can say is like NFL football has
changed the way stand-up comedy has
changed in the last couple of years to
the point like you don't even [ __ ]
recognize it you know I'm sitting here
watching other comedians going on radio
shows and and in social media attacking
other [ __ ] comedians and literally
saying what they should or shouldn't be
saying on stage is like what the [ __ ] am
i watching and I watch NFL football you
know you can't hit a quarterback below
the knees you can't hit him in the head
he can have the ball and you if you
tackle them too hard
or in one of those areas its roughing
the [ __ ] passer if you simply push
them down onto the ground
it's roughing the [ __ ] passer dude
how many [ __ ] times by the way will a
quarterback throw a [ __ ] [ __ ] ball
and the defensive back goes up to
intercepted and then the white at that
point the defensive back has position
and the wide receiver is behind him on
his back hands all [ __ ] over them it
breaks up the [ __ ] pass not only is
it not interference
the guys in the booth go that was a
heads-up play that's why you have
everybody's thrown for 5,000 yards
50 [ __ ] touchdowns is all I'm [ __ ]
saying which is why you can't go back
and look at Joe Montana and say that he
is somehow inferior to Tom Brady I just
don't buy it all right so here we go
again
now I'm gonna age another 10,000 [ __ ]
years and [ __ ] all you guys ago you
[ __ ] spoiled Patriots fan go [ __ ]
yourself
okay walk a mile in my [ __ ] shoes
I've been in your shoes well you never
[ __ ] get there that sucks losing an
AFC Championship game sucks I'll tell
you what's worse losing a [ __ ] Super
Bowl when the whole world's watching so
the next time you go to Belgium some
[ __ ] shows up with the [ __ ] yeah
you know Giants are an Eagles shirt and
you get worldwide [ __ ] for that loss so
anyways I'm just an old curmudgeon who
would like to see more of a balanced
game but I also think because of that
CTE [ __ ] they kind of have to protect
everybody so I do love seeing defensive
players hitting with their shoulders and
not hitting guys in the head I do like
that aspect of the [ __ ] game and you
know I don't know other than that I
don't know what the I don't even know
what the [ __ ] I watched yesterday and I
have been consistent with that the whole
[ __ ] year all right I hated that
Chiefs Rams game and as much as you guys
gonna just sit there saying I'm some
whining Patriots fan there was literally
NFL players tweeting what the [ __ ] I was
saying Tedy Bruschi Richard Sherman they
all said the same thing I did and you
[ __ ] [ __ ] don't bring that up do you
do ya all right all right
you know what it is it's also because
now I have a kid and I can't get out all
this [ __ ] energy like I just sit
there stoic Lee and then it just [ __ ]
builds up so I'm sorry I'm regurgitating
all of this [ __ ]
having said that congratulations to the
ramps you know you're not making the
calls out there my condolences to the
saint's fans that was my pick I did not
like the Patriots chances against the
Saints I don't really like him against
the Rams either to be honest with you
I definitely think the NFC stronger and
my condolences to chief fans all I can
say is that you're gonna I you're
definitely the team in the future in the
AFC unless I don't know Brady keeps
[ __ ] drinking his vampire blood and
plays until he's 45 but even then my
homes are so [ __ ] young I don't know
I don't know anyways yes this weekend
celebrated my daughter's second birthday
I made a [ __ ] birthday cake like a
champ sorry I'm [ __ ] I'm sorry I'm
[ __ ] spent from both of those games
yesterday I had those games and my
daughter's birthday so the whole first
part of the day was stressing out that
Mike no one was gonna like my birthday
cake running around making sure you know
the the bubble lady was showing up who
crushed it by the way we had a guy come
by did the music portion everybody loved
that and we built it perfectly and then
there was the bubble lady and then we
did the birthday cake it was perfect
opener Midler headliner you know the
whole thing worked out and the kids
freaked out the bubble ad was like
next-level my kids love [ __ ] bubbles
all you have is that little [ __ ] wand
you know that you blow the bubbles
through and then this lady came down
with like [ __ ] four kiddie pools with
these bubbles the size of like special
effects of a summertime blockbuster and
these kids were like is this really
happening like they didn't care about it
they don't even care about cake after
that she shut down the birthday cake
with the bubble display that she put on
you know other parents where they're
going where did you find this person
they were getting her information she
was crushing it you know it was like
watching a comedian do a private gig and
there was like three other companies
there and he gets he gets like three
four more [ __ ] gigs out of it
[Music]
I don't know I don't know I feel like I
went too [ __ ] hard on the officiating
in the [ __ ] game that's going on but
I just I don't know maybe I'm just worn
out watching the [ __ ] games but
anyways plowing ahead here so we knocked
all of that out and then I watched then
my daughter takes her nap and I watched
that first the first game and then she
woke up we did more birthday stuff then
I watched the Patriots game on tape
delay and now it's the next morning I'm
like just [ __ ] worn out here I can't
[ __ ] believe they're in another Super
Bowl I can't [ __ ] believe it
I'm [ __ ] wheel does Brady have but if
they win this do you think Brady retires
the guy should retire right then he goes
was he half he's got he'd have six he
would be tied with the Steelers who for
some reason are considered the New York
Yankees of NFL football you know I've
never really gotten anybody to [ __ ]
explain to me why they don't count
NFL titles because the the Packers are
the team and then it then I think it's
like the Giants because the Giants have
won four Super Bowls and I don't how
many NFL titles they've won let me check
this [ __ ] out
I love this nerd [ __ ] here alright New
York Giants your New York Giants alright
what do they got here alright Eastern I
don't even tell me that
okay NFL championships pre-1970 they
have four so the way I see it you know I
should make a list of these things the
[ __ ] New York Giants have eight
titles for NFL titles and four Super
Bowls so they should be ahead of the
Patriots because
we have five Super Bowls that's it
and I wouldn't count AFL titles the same
way you don't count a b8 championships
the ABA merged with the NBA and the
Celtics still got to keep all their
championships and the Minneapolis Lakers
got to keep those the [ __ ] Lakers
even kept a baa championship that they
somehow count as an NBA championship
I'll never not bring that up
alright you know Stanley Cups go all the
way back to early [ __ ] 1900s in World
Series they think they give the [ __ ]
Philadelphia Phillies let me look them
up they get correct they won one in
[ __ ] 1880 you know they want to win
in like 18 [ __ ] 80 we're like if you
brought it up like hey how come in 1880
if you brought up like hey how come
there's no black people on your team
first of all they'd say what's a black
person and then refer say you mean n
words you mean former slaves like that's
how long ago it was where are we what
happened how many they want let's see
that major toilet World Series
oh wait 1980 they haven't won one look
back don't wait I know I said okay I put
it on the Phillies who the [ __ ] was it
first World Series baseball oh I always
thought when they won in 1980 they had
one in a hundred [ __ ] years
oh the 1903 World Series was the first
modern World Series is that the first
one that they count wait a second wait a
second
1884 World Series alright in baseball
the 1884 World Series was a postseason
championship between the Providence
Grays of the National League and the New
York Metropolitan's of the American
associations at the Polo Grounds in New
York City which is now in it's in Harlem
there's a little plaque up there I
looked at it one time
by myself because I'm weird while the
postseason championship series was the
first such to be referred to as the
World Series Major League Baseball
considers 1903 World Series the first
I've been saying that for years
[ __ ] on the Phillies and no one's
ever corrected me at least I didn't see
it
alright so 1903 let's see the 1903 World
Series
alright 1903 World Series was the Boston
Americans versus the Pittsburgh Pirates
in the Boston Americans 1 5 2 3 whatever
[ __ ] five games to three so it was best
five out of nine whatever happened to
the Boston Americans say this is the
[ __ ] here this is why being a sports fan
is great and then also this is what I'm
going to lose my Boston Americans wiki
pedia the Boston Americans Boston Red
Sox are an American professional
baseball team based in Boston
Massachusetts wait a minute the Red Sox
compete the major league baseball waited
that's not our first World Series title
is it it is that's us two three four
five six seven eight nine we were called
the Boston Americans world series bah
bah bah bah bah bah I didn't I had no
idea I didn't know that 1903 now who the
[ __ ] played in that game if the Boston
Red Sox can count in 1903 I mean we
didn't like their way there was no
option to fly to a game no one had ever
flown before
[Music]
90 no [ __ ] three ladies gentlemen how
about a round of applause while our
heroes from the spanish-american war
che and I might try something Shady
that was still [ __ ] 20 years away
they didn't even have motion pictures
Jesus Christ their [ __ ] mascot was
probably a [ __ ] dodo burgers probably
still alive back then name the only
[ __ ] major league baseball team with
an endangered species that was at the
[ __ ] ballpark when it won its first
World Series all right now if they can
count that [ __ ] why do I care why do I
care this much all right Stanley Cup
champion list of Stanley Cup champions
how far back do they go 1890 [ __ ] and
three the Montreal hockey club now you
can't tell me that they played an arena
in an arena that had that Buick on the
[ __ ] pond 1893 aah ac champions , no
challengers Montreal hockey called the
Montreal victorious tomorrow let's look
for the first like Montreal Canadiens or
a team that I recognize the Winnipeg
Victoria so they moved out to Winnipeg
then weather then they moved to Phoenix
after that Montreal hockey club Montreal
hockey club this is 1903 Ottawa Ottawa
Senators 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 [ __ ]
years in a row in 1903 the Ottawa hockey
club beat the rat porridge thistles all
right I
I think I have to get a rat porridge
[ __ ] hockey jersey the Canora
thistles they originally known as the
rat porridge thistles all right I got to
look this up you can't tell me Mitchell
and Ness has not put out a [ __ ] rat
porridge thistle yet jersey rat porch
disel Jersey images oh we have a Jersey
I don't know you can buy it and there's
no rat on it it's got the thistle on it
ah you [ __ ] [ __ ] somebody's wife
came up with that [ __ ] name Canora
thistles third string goalie 1907
thistle Tommy Tommy Phillips Jersey well
would you look at that Jesus Christ look
at the team photo of the [ __ ] rat
porridge thistle all right now I'm gonna
say the guy in the front row on the left
was the one who came up with that logo
if not the other guy on the left in the
second row and those two guys might may
have been dating each other that's what
I'm getting out of that photo not to say
that there's anything wrong with it okay
progressive lifestyles have existed for
a long time they just haven't been
recognized anyways plowing ahead here
I'll tell you what I'll make a promise
you this is the last time I don't know
if I can do that I would say the last
time that I'm gonna complain about
[ __ ] all of these [ __ ] Sports
Jesus Christ can you guys at least give
me that I'm making at least a little bit
of a decent point you know how many
times you're gonna watch a guy drive the
lane in the NBA now and the defender
literally get out of the way cuz he
doesn't want to end up on [ __ ]
Instagram I mean that just didn't happen
back in the [ __ ] day all right let me
read some let me read some advertising
here all right oh look who's here old
zip
you know what's not smart pick one of
the following feel free to make it your
own job boards that send you candidates
that aren't qualified for the role you
posted but you know it is smart
that's the only one they gave me going
to zip recruited comm / BER to hire the
right person
unlike other job sites if Berta finds
qualified candidates for you some reason
they capitalize for fines Canon call it
finds qualified candidates for you it's
powerful matching technology scans
thousands of resumes to identify people
with the right skills education and
experience and actively invites them to
apply to your job so you get quality
candidates fast yeah it's like tinder
for employees
that's why zip recruiter is rated number
one by employers in the US this rating
comes from hiring sites on trust pilot
with over 1000 reviews and right now my
listeners can try zip okay
for free at this exclusive web site
address zip recruit at comm / / if you
love this show show your support to it
and zip recruiter by going to zip
recruit at comm / / that zip recruited
comm / / hi zip the smartest way to hire
all right simply safe
all right simply safe so here's a timely
stat for you almost half of us make a
new year's resolution every single year
we've all made them and most of us have
probably broken them I kind of have but
my whole I'm not arguing with my wife
has been working great oh man I got to
have her on the [ __ ] podcast and talk
maybe this Thursday we're gonna talk
about me buying a I was looking for a
birthday candle from my daughter's cake
alright I'm just gonna
tee's the story and I went there you
know I just wanted the number two I'm
making a chocolate cake I'm thinking
something silver you know something like
you know looking like that right and I
show up and all that all the numbers
were all like this
tie-dye rainbow color and I had a
paranoid meltdown and refused to buy one
and I bought the silver candles anyways
and I'll have Nia come on and grill me
as to why I did that I was just trying
to have an agenda free birthday cake for
a two-year-old that's all I wanted
alright happens to happens to the best
of us where am I happens to the best of
us but one resolution worth sticking to
this year keeping your home and family
safe that's why I recommend simply safe
home security simply safe is 24/7 home
security with no contracts or caches
they believe the safest place on earth
should be your own home so you feel
protected every time you shut your door
and leave for work or shut your eyes at
night more than three million people
already feel this way every day thanks
to simply safe and they're not the only
ones
the folks at PC Mag names simply save
both editors choice and Readers Choice
for 2018-2019 feels like a good year to
ask yourself is my home as safe as it
could be and if you're thinking well
maybe this is the year to change that
get simply safe go just go to simply
save bird calm to get started that's
simply safe bird calm to protect your
home and family today simply safe BRR
calm and it's spelled si MP Li safe calm
all right plowing plow Inc ahead Oh Oh
Billy boos face Oh Billy boos face also
has not been drinking maybe that's why
I'm being such a [ __ ] [ __ ] about the
new NFL you know ruining ruining it for
younger people this isn't it football I
thought what I was watching was football
you old bald [ __ ]
I'm gonna get a lot of [ __ ] I don't give
a [ __ ] though some
[ __ ] [ __ ] sent me some are you not
entertained it's like no I'm not I like
[ __ ] I like all aspects of football
not just scoring fat girlfriend I
actually think that they're doing it for
fantasy football numbers I think that
that's another reason why they're doing
CTE
mixed with fantasy [ __ ] football and
all of that [ __ ] you know so people can
keep up with this stupid goddamn like I
hate that guy but he's on my fantasy
team all right you know what I'm right
I'm not backing down from what the [ __ ]
I said what the [ __ ] you're watching now
is not goddamn football it's it's it's
the goddamn [ __ ] Ice Capades all
right there I said it
and all you douche bags who play fantasy
[ __ ] football you can go I'll go [ __ ]
yourselves to there I took a stand I'm
trying I'm tired of trying to be [ __ ]
like diplomatic on this but I understand
the game's change
I understand these concussions go [ __ ]
yourself a rookie should not be throwing
for 50 [ __ ] touchdowns playin NFL
football all right if you don't believe
me go ask [ __ ] Ray Lewis what he
thinks about that all right
fat girlfriend hey Bill I'm a girl
listener writing him with advice for a
guy with the fat girlfriend yes okay we
had a we had a a male listener all right
I don't know if he had a man bun I don't
know if he had a flattop
I don't know how progressive he was I
don't know if he was an ally I don't
know if he likes the new [ __ ] rules
in NFL football I know if he wants to
see more scoring I know if he's an old
[ __ ] grizzled [ __ ] like me I don't
know what this guy is but he has a
girlfriend there was a little [ __ ]
you know had some pounds on her he's
like all right you know whatever we're
gonna relay she [ __ ] maybe I'll get out
there on the treadmill but no she kept
eating cupcakes and she's getting to the
point that she's a [ __ ] house so he
still loves her and he wants to how do
you tell somebody that they're they're
not attractive to you because they've
eaten so much as a man as a woman I know
you can [ __ ] do that you can say that
to a guy because nobody gives a [ __ ]
about a man or his goddamned feelings
despite how much these broads [ __ ]
[ __ ] about how difficult their lives
are
you know and everybody's all brave now
fair woman and they're [ __ ] out of
shape when reality is is you're killing
yourself it's not good for you it's not
healthy and you're not brave you're
being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
who's in denial I'm not saying you
should [ __ ] hate yourself but to just
pate I'm doing heroin look at my abs hey
I'm eating doughnuts every [ __ ] day
I've almost closed three out of four of
my [ __ ] arteries whatever you call
them is that what you call them the
things that go on come out of your heart
the [ __ ] the intake I'll take hose
from the radiator yeah you're not brave
you're you're [ __ ] in denial all
right when somebody calls tells you that
you need to drop some weight there
they're helping you prolong your life
all right you can't make someone care
about their weight that's what this
woman says cuz I asked for a woman to
come in she said I wish I had better
news for him but if his girlfriend
doesn't want to lose weight and it
sounds like she doesn't then she won't
if it's a deal-breaker he needs to break
up with her and if it's not then he has
to get over it
oh my god you know something if you were
here right now and I had your permission
in writing in in triplicate I would give
you a hug all right one of those hugs
will you [ __ ] lean in it's only the
tops of your shoulders touch the tops of
them and you do like a [ __ ] even you
inside of your heads don't touch they
post me to hug I would give you okay
that mindset right there that mindset
right there is what makes you great that
that right there is everything you need
to be successful in life all right
it [ __ ] it that was just that was and
that was perfect let me read that again
I wish I had better news for him but if
his girlfriend doesn't want to lose
weight and it sounds like she doesn't
she won't in other words you can't make
somebody you know get their [ __ ]
together they have to want to get their
[ __ ] together okay so now that we've
solved that that it's not on you to make
somebody care about themselves all right
now you have to deal with the situation
so this is what it is okay and if you
can handle it get
over it if you can't break up with them
but other than that shut the [ __ ] up
about it that's it and I actually think
I actually feel for this guy cuz if he
loves her he's he's gonna watch her take
10-15 years off her [ __ ] life and he
hasn't even knocked her up yet cuz
that's the other thing like with women
you got to give women a pass on at least
20 [ __ ] pounds 25 pounds you have to
because they have kids you know we got
kids and they got to deal with the whole
chemical [ __ ] thing of that thinking
that postpartum and all of that [ __ ] you
know what I mean but as men
you got no [ __ ] excuse they got p90x
out there they got that robe fitness
they got all of this [ __ ] out there
there's no excuse as always fellas we
have no excuse as always you will be
held responsible for your actions that's
amazing that was an amazing response
because I couldn't come up like if you
haven't been listening I tried to come
up with a response for it and a proper
angle and I could not come up with one
and even the lovely Nia came on and she
listened to it and she took it
personally like I wrote the email to her
but my wife is cool so when I called
around her and she laughed but it took
this person here this anonymous person
look at that not even leaving a name
didn't want any sort of credit what's so
[ __ ] ever all right ladies response
to guy with over weight girlfriend okay
now there's gonna be a tough one there's
gonna be a tough one to follow up ladies
response to guy with overweight
girlfriend hey Bill
when I was in my mid-20s I was dating my
long-term boyfriend I wasn't models
skinny when we met but we were dining
out a lot and I had put on some weight
one night we had a really honest
conversation that served as a wake-up
call for me he was a hundred percent
honest and told me he wasn't attracted
to me with the extra weight was it hard
harsh yes
was it hurtful yes
however I took our conversation
seriously and for for the first time in
my life I actually thought about my own
health and what I was putting into my
into my body in my body sorry I if Nia
ever said to me you've put on weight and
I'm not attracted to you like as she was
saying it I would start putting on my
gym clothes I'm not saying my bottom lip
wouldn't be quivering and there wouldn't
be tears in my eyes but I would get my
[ __ ] fat pasty freckled ass to the
nearest goddamn elliptical okay and then
I would deal with my feelings later I
would immediately go right to the
solution working out but what we live in
a different time now where it's just
when you sit there and you hold
somebody's hand right to an early grave
you know is the hole too deep that we
dug that you're gonna die in would you
like some [ __ ] love some bubble wrap
down on the bottom when you faceplant
from a major [ __ ] heart attack we
started working out together and eating
better together
we both got in better shape win-win look
at that because of his honesty I
realized how important being healthy is
not not to mention it's not fair to the
[ __ ] person you're with male or
female to to let yourself go okay I'm
not gonna be a hundred percent harsh
because I know there's a bunch of
emotional reasons that people start
eating so get into therapy figure that
out and get your ass to the gym and take
control of your [ __ ] life the problem
with today's oh my god I am the old man
today the the [ __ ] Photoshop has to
be me sitting on my front porch the
problem with all this [ __ ]
understanding is you're now we've gone
from going hey tubby why don't you lay
off the cupcakes to like calling the
person brave for eating cupcakes then I
think there has to
an adjustment somewhere in the middle
like even like that meat to [ __ ] like
this whole [ __ ] thing had to happen
because no one was listening to these
women's complaints right so then the
[ __ ] cork blows off the bottle and
then it becomes due process is out the
window the burden of proof is now on the
person accused they have to somehow
clear their name where the person who
accuses them doesn't have to have any
evidence they just now you just need to
adjust it back where now we're gonna
listen to women and there's going to be
do processed that it's the safest way to
[ __ ] do this [ __ ] right adjust it
back the same thing with fat people you
can't just [ __ ] guy a tub of [ __ ] hey
lard-ass [ __ ] you know go eat a salad
you're [ __ ] fat [ __ ] you can't do
that but to go the entire other way and
just say they're brave and they should
be proud of their body and start making
[ __ ] you know car covers into [ __ ]
sweatpants I don't think is another good
it's a good way to do you're not helping
him that way either all right so this is
great so he had this painful [ __ ]
conversation and she turned this hurt
into a positive but now I would think
that they're in shape banging each other
anyways because of his honesty I
realized how important it is to be
healthy I started reading more about
diet and fitness listening to fitness
podcast cooking us healthy meals and
continued to work out educating myself
and taking the time to care for myself
has an all capital letters changed my
life I ended up losing 50 pounds and
keeping it off all because he had the
courage to tell me his truth okay I
loved everything until you used that
expression he's living his [ __ ] I'm
living my truth all because he said what
the [ __ ] was on his mind anyways and
he's and she said and I wasn't too
sensitive to be able to see my
shortcomings and improve on them you
know something I wish I could send this
to anybody trying to get over a [ __ ]
problem that's been confronted you
should have this [ __ ] you know stick
into a pillow old-fashioned needlepoint
or something like this this is what you
got to do alright cuz I'll you know this
[ __ ] that I'm doing right now with my
wife she [ __ ] came at me basically
straight up telling me how what a
difficult [ __ ] I was to live with and
anybody who listened to me
bitching about NFL football after I just
watched my team win a game to go to the
Super Bowl can understand what my wife
has to go through if I'm bitching about
that right so I decided that I was gonna
just turn it around
other than being like oh she's beautiful
what about the stuff you do I knew she
was right so I mean there's two ways
when somebody comes at you you could be
like [ __ ] you I'm brave and I'm just
speaking my truth and eating my my
dreams you know whatever the [ __ ] it is
you're doing
do you realize Americans how [ __ ]
dumb you sound to the rest of the world
when you're saying you're living your
truth and I don't mean other first world
countries so go [ __ ] yourself England
Germany and all you [ __ ] who will
laughing right now
I mean how dumb you sound to the rest of
the [ __ ] world that's actually
struggling that you're living your truth
well you know kids in their [ __ ]
country have to sell your clothes
together for an extra [ __ ] hour
because you now feel brave for being a
fat [ __ ] I mean it's it's hilarious
anyways she goes on to say I'm actually
grateful to him because if he hadn't had
the courage to have had that
conversation with me I probably still be
eating junk yeah you could have been a
[ __ ] diabetic lost a couple of toes
not exercising and continuing an
unhealthy lifestyle that would cause
issues for me as I age yeah and some
days you have kids and you're gonna die
sooner in my opinion sometimes tough
love is necessary if you have a strong
relationship you should be able to be
100% open and honest with each other
about everything including this love
tunia and the baby Jesus Christ why
don't more women right into this podcast
Oh
right because I'm the host those are all
[ __ ] like both of those goddamn
emails what I love about them was they
were both sides of the argument what the
guy had to do and what the woman has to
do in that thing you know and they're
also interchangeable so if you're a man
listening to this and you're actually in
the position of the woman where you're
your wife or girlfriend has come at you
with some tough love
yeah don't be a [ __ ] baby about it oh
now I'm on my [ __ ] tree stump here
you know III have been unlikable a lot
on my [ __ ] podcast I think this is
probably the most unlikable zip
recruiter wait didn't I already read all
this [ __ ] oh sorry I scrolled up too far
all right
10-year challenge and conspiracy stuff
oh okay oh this is some consumer tell me
a great joke about a conspiracy theorist
instead of conspiracy theories dies and
goes to heaven or at least he's having
his interview to try to get into heaven
and he meets God and God says all right
congratulations sir you lived a great
life you've made it into heaven and
there's one of your rewards I will
answer you know whatever your top
question is that you've ever had in life
he goes off thank God
I wanna I have to know who is it that
killed John F Kennedy who were the
people that killed him and he said well
I can answer that easily he goes it was
Leo Lee Harvey Oswald it was you know it
was him and he acted alone and the
conspiracy theorists grossed out Jesus
this goes higher than I thought I'm sure
I butchered it anyways 10-year challenge
and conspiracy stuff dear Bill
Illuminati Illuminati oh Jesus I loved
it all right what are your thoughts on
the 10 year challenge my thoughts are if
you're an adult you shouldn't be doing
that
that just sounds like something a
teenager would be doing oh I'm such an
old grumpy [ __ ] that's what children
grow up get busy with diet it's the
social media thing where people post a
pic of themselves from 10 years ago and
today to show how much or little they've
changed wire did an article about the
shady dating data collecting involved
with it also I'm 23 so when I started
listening to you in 2011 I was younger
and definitely intrigued by the
conspiracy stuff but never had enough of
a perspective on history and everything
till now I'd let I've read a lot more
about that crazy [ __ ]
history is fetes while I don't believe
that the moon is actually an alien base
I do believe that the official story is
often [ __ ] yeah that's called being
enlightened but for a lot of people
they'll still say oh what are you
putting on your tinfoil hat
yeah the official story is usual usually
ninety percent of the time is [ __ ]
and all you have to do is just look at
yourself as a human being anytime you
get in trouble anytime there's a
controversy you know how much you're
spinning it you know I've always said
you know when it when was has a cop ever
pulled up to a two car accident and one
person says the [ __ ] guy came out of
nowhere and t-boned me and then when he
walked up to the other guy the other guy
the cop goes what happened and the other
guy goes man I came out of [ __ ]
nowhere and t-boned him it's always
gonna be like his version of it and
they're both [ __ ] in the right
anyways he said I think the most
frustrating thing is how little people
care about Declassified files that
confirms that was once crazy talk yeah
because they view it as this weird way
their perception they view it as this
isn't how things have been handled
historically and continue to be handled
today they view it as well all those
people who said that [ __ ] were dead are
dead now that stuff happened before I
was born they for some reason cannot
make the leap until an up and
the modern error like my wife just sent
me something whether it was a family you
know that was dealing in the business of
oxycontin and how they are being accused
there's all these emails of them
suppressing information about how
[ __ ] addictive that stuff was and if
that is true those people you know if
they don't get the death penalty what
they've done to people what they've done
to families and I'm you know I know like
three close personal friends of mine
that are have dealt with it or dealing
with it and I don't know and just all of
this [ __ ] I mean come on again but what
kills me now is now because corporations
own media and all of this [ __ ] the same
ones who are [ __ ] us over who dictate
our foreign policy if you criticize
anything about that then then they just
go and they wipe out your [ __ ] career
but anyways as far as the 10-year
challenge I mean yeah they're definitely
data collecting data I would think and
they're selling data and then it just
gets to who are they selling it to and
what are they going to use it for like
that 10-year challenge stuff if you give
that to the police that could help them
find a missing kid but then it's also
you know it's like anything if it falls
into the wrong [ __ ] hands like
there's nothing wrong with an ar-15
until a [ __ ] lunatic gets one there's
nothing wrong with guns until some
[ __ ] [ __ ] gets one so then that
becomes the thing that people then
debate because there's morons out there
should nobody have them is there a way
to control who gets them bla bla bla bla
bla all of that [ __ ] so I don't know
well welcome to the frustrating world of
being at least of enlightened I'm not
saying enlightened like you're 100%
right on everything that you're thinking
about but to sit there and say that the
official story is often [ __ ] yeah it
is often [ __ ] right from why a team
got rid of a player to why we're
fighting a war all of it is gonna be
spun
I'll tell you what's hilarious when I
was overseas I kept doing this thing
saying like in the middle of my act I
would just be like you know what now I'm
gonna take time out of my act to talk
about the greatest country in the world
the United States of America
okay and everyone would start laughing
and then all I wouldn't even do jokes I
would just start spewing out our
propaganda beacons of freedom defending
the rights of blah blah blah and
everybody bursting out laughing like I
was doing stand-up comedy and all I was
doing was just saying what my government
says to me what we're doing all right I
did that in every city all seven
countries and they all left okay now
yeah you're gonna [ __ ] tell me that
that by doing that as a test because I
knew that they were gonna laugh but I
just wanted to see like how hard they
were gonna laugh how could I just sit
there and be like well what what I'm
being told is a hundred percent [ __ ]
truth there has to be at least another
side to this [ __ ] story right I don't
know anyways plowing ahead here I I
would personally I wouldn't do that I
wouldn't send my DNA into the internet
to find out what percentage German Irish
English French whatever the [ __ ] I am
I do think you know it's fascinating to
figure that out but I just don't trust
people that have you know I mean one of
the biggest light that the brand new the
new checks in the mail I used to be the
old lie the the modern version of that
lie is this is a secure site none of
them are secure and you should be
guarding everything that you can but at
this point even with myself I just
thinks you know it's too late like so
much [ __ ] is out there but just because
that's too late doesn't mean you can't
educate your kids to not do that and I
don't know I I am amazed with you know
all of what the stalkers that are out
there especially with women that the
fact that you can go on the internet and
essentially
find anybody and figure out you know
where they are and also that you know if
you're not paying attention like you'll
send out a [ __ ] something to one of
these social media sites and a little
ease will say your location where you're
at in that moment I don't know like how
can that end up being a good [ __ ]
thing all right money free time and
seclusion Jesus Christ I think you're
describing my dreams my goals my life
goals living my truth
having money free time in seclusion is
great a dear Billy lifestyle I'm 37
years old and just started making really
good money I used to work a [ __ ] job for
a government contractor I spent 12 years
working 9:00 to 5:00 and two Saturdays a
month now I work 15 to 20 hours a week
and make three times as much hey welcome
to the world of dealing drugs the
difference is with that with all this
free time I don't feel like being social
anymore I don't have the same amount of
steam to blow off and my free time is
almost more valuable because I know what
to do with it I'm drinking less and feel
great my friends think I'm being lame
but [ __ ] them do you see any problem
with any of this am i leading myself
down a path to die alone if I do die
alone it'll certainly be peaceful all
right well I'm not saying die alone but
I also did you're just becoming an adult
you know what I mean you're becoming
like yeah you don't need to go out and
go out listen to go out to some [ __ ]
bar
where you have to scream over the
goddamn music just sitting there getting
hammered or whether whatever blowing
money I think I don't know how can I put
this here all right I don't think you're
being lame because you wanna because you
know you don't go out that's just that's
just becoming an adult your your [ __ ]
adult that's all it is all right and
when by you growing up your
freaking them out because it's like wait
a minute this is the party over and I'm
still at it am i that guy but I would
stop short of dying alone you what I
would do is with your free time rather
than go out to bars go out and do some
sort of activity like I don't know what
the softball league or some [ __ ] I'm old
I don't know what they I mean I'm so old
go rollerblading join a rollerblade team
I'm from the 90s I don't [ __ ] know go
play Wally ball I think that sports
finally gonna take off which was
volleyball combined with Wolfe I would
do something positive like that short of
joining a church group and I would do
that and then maybe you'll meet a great
woman there who also doesn't need to go
out and [ __ ] do Jager shots well into
your 30s congratulations you're finding
out what makes you happy and you're
working smarter you're working smarter
speaking of working smarter we I have a
big announcement that's coming out
tomorrow on Tuesday I'm not allowed to
say it but it's announcement about a
certain project so check in on my social
media sites if you have the time if you
don't I understand and I'll just bring
it up on Thursday and I'll tell you
anyways all right thinking about
breaking up with my girlfriend Oh JJ's
hey Billy big-time as the title suggests
I'm thinking about breaking up with my
girlfriend we've been going out for
three years - a break in the middle I
broke up with her last summer but like a
[ __ ] I got back together with her a
month later after failed prospects oh
boy that is not a reason to get back
together with her and you're already
saying like a [ __ ] yeah you should yeah
okay she is what I would call wife
material responsible good-looking can
cook caring you know my only problem is
we don't have sex don't get me wrong we
get physical but it usually ends in
either a high or nothing H I parentheses
same thing for her because it's all she
lets me do
I can't read that word that's written my
I need glasses here what I don't know is
that some new young slang a high H I
don't get me wrong we get physical I can
feel all you guys laughing at me that I
don't know what this means we get
physical but I usually but it usually
ends in either a high or nothing she
just says hello same thing for her
because it's all she lets me do she's
Catholic enough for it to be annoying
and falls back on it when we talk about
controversial [ __ ] anytime I try to have
a productive conversation she sandbags
with excuses dude I don't know what
you're talking about here is she a
virgin anyways I don't have a problem
that she's Catholic it's just gets
irritating when she pulls out the
religious propaganda I'm not religious
but I'm also not a douche bag atheist I
just don't give a [ __ ] I need help here
bill
you need help explain what is the [ __ ] I
don't get what's going on you're saying
oh you don't have sex at all I thought
you meant by we don't have sex as we
barely have sex anymore so you're saying
we don't have sex at all she's cat
because she's Catholic okay I need help
here bill it was fun while it lasted but
I feel like I'm wasting my time now to
me sex is a whole other side of a
relationship to her it isn't that's fine
we're different in this fact if I break
up with her I'm not going back not doing
that that [ __ ] again by the way we're
both 21 and I haven't had sex yet
not by choice and neither is she oh all
right
PS I know it's late but I [ __ ] love
your show at the Altria killed as usual
i drugged my family along I think I say
i drugged my family i drugged my family
along forgot where that theater was even
though i occasionally worked security
for the ax there miss dinner and almost
missed the show according to them 15
minutes early is [ __ ] perfect for me
they forgot all about it after the show
if you want more details about my
problem let me know all right see you
both 21
alright dude I'm just gonna go back to
what that woman's advice was all right
you can't change people I would want to
pressure somebody into doing something
especially sexually that they didn't
want to [ __ ] do so
either you accept that this is what she
wants to do it you [ __ ] walk I mean
that's it you stood by the big thing
that sticks with me you just said I
broke up with there last summer but like
a [ __ ] I got back together with her a
month later after failed prospects so it
seems to me you think it was dumb to get
back with her and that a month later
because you know you weren't banging
somebody you got scared that you're
gonna be all alone I think you both want
two different things
alright and this is a major thing and if
that's how she wants to live her life
you have to respect it and if you want
to go out and go bang somebody you
should go out and go bang him so I would
say go out and do what's gonna make you
happy and that's it and when you break
up with her don't [ __ ] get back
together with her unless you're gonna be
able to deal with the fact that she's
never gonna bang you until you are just
marry her put a ring on it man put a
ring on it
and then [ __ ] her put a ring on it don't
have any [ __ ] [ __ ] her and then divorce
her
that's the worst karma ever don't do
that alright that's it the crabby old
man on this podcast that's it I stand by
my fire I would love to hear you guys
[ __ ] opinions you guys can call me a
[ __ ] old man or whatever I would love
to have your opinions on is anybody else
old like me and you just remembered like
you know defense was [ __ ] allowed I
don't know I have no idea anyways that's
it that's the podcast go [ __ ] yourselves
and I'll check in on you on Thursday
Hey look for my announcement tomorrow
bye